here
if
Well, good morning again church. It's an honor to get
to do this most every week to preach the word and
to Pastor. I love doing it. So I
look back over the last four years and can see how much I've grown through
a lot of trial and a lot of God's work in that but also
do to a lot of your encouragement. And so thank
you again for that. If you are new to our church, we'd
love to meet you. So just come say hello up here
after or out the info desk. We just want to get to know you and care for
you as best we can.
So come say hello.
As we get into this today, though.
I have a deep concern about where we live.
About where I even grew up up in Northwest Oklahoma in
the Buckle of what would be called the Bible
Belt that we often refer to?
see many of you have heard my testimony where I grew up in an
environment where there were thankfully a lot of solid followers
of Christ that were there, but there was also
an accepted level of what we
would call cultural Christianity.
Where people just kind of going through the motions but not
really changed.
Having the right answers to the questions, but where Jesus is mostly
just fire insurance for eternity.
Maybe even some kind of moral encouragement or decency that
you would want to live.
But it's wrong is that culture is many of us I think
can identify with that.
That's where we have been.
But it's wrong as that culture is what that can breed
in US.
Is is an arrogance toward others?
where we we look down on others who don't
have it all together like we claim to have
or we we begin to create this class system,
where where you you exclude others
who don't have the right background or the right lifestyle
or the right? Whatever they're not
worthy of our love.
or God's love
Yet the whole time that is happening. That first
group just assumes that they're okay with
God.
That we're right with God.
And thinking that that second group.
no chance of getting in
The parable we're going to study today as they
all have done so far will continue to separate.
Those who are humbly looking for God's kingdom to come.
From those who are self-righteous and selfish and creating
wrong barriers.
So we're gonna learn from this Parable that at God's table eternally
God's table in fellowship with God the expected
are absent.
while the unexpected or present
that's the idea. We're going to see today in the parable. Is that that at Eternal
table God's table?
The expected are actually absent but the unexpected.
present
we'll see that in Luke chapter 14 today. So
take your copy of God's word turn there with me.
Luke 14 again put a bookmark in Luke
were in there all summer, of course.
Luke 14 and we'll get to the first part of it
before we get to the parable in a moment, but we've done this with
all the Parables so far is we need to study the context for why he
would tell it.
Well the context here in the first part of chapter 14 is that he
was telling this at a Sabbath feast.
So we'll see he's been invited to a feast on the
Sabbath. And so that was the context this sabbath Feast
where he was telling the parable will see a little bit later.
And meals back then were critically important
because it was a place that they would gather together to celebrate
or to praise God or to
honor someone or to pass along critical information
that needed to be shared.
So they throw a party big feast and here Jesus Takes the
context this part he's been invited to to share some
important information.
about eternity
And who is invited who gets in to the kingdom of God eternally?
But Jesus needed to prepare their hearts to hear it first. And so
that's we're going to see him confront some things in these religious leaders lives
that he's around.
The first thing he confronts is their religious traditions.
In this Feast he confronts their religious Traditions.
Look at verses 1 through 6 here.
One Sabbath when he went into dine at the house of a
ruler of the Pharisees. They were watching him carefully trying to
trap him usually and behold there was a man before him who
had drop scene now that's a condition where there's
too much fluid buildup in your joints and body and
just can't really function can't move very easily and so
it hindered your life.
And Jesus responded to the lawyers and the Pharisees
saying is it lawful to heal on the
Sabbath or not?
But they remain silent and he took him and healed him
and sent him away.
And he said to the leaders, which of you having a son or
an ox that's fallen into a well on a Sabbath day will not
immediately pull him out.
And they could not reply to these things.
Now before you come down too hard on the Pharisees.
Right Phil said this week like we tend to think of the
Pharisees like like Jafar from Aladdin right? Like just
the worst thing you could ever imagine. That's that's what we think of these guys.
But but honestly think about this they were trying to follow the law.
I was that was really the motivation. They didn't do it
well or perfectly but but it was it was an attempt
to follow God's law and even all the
way from the well-known Ten Commandments that God had
commanded no work on the Sabbath.
So that was in their mind. They're trying to figure out ways to obey that
not to disobey that they wanted to make sure they were on track with
that command at least one of them.
But their hearts were off as they were
trying to do that.
So why Jesus says what he says he says you would have broken
that command if your son fell in that well or if
an ox, you're source of income fell in that well, right
you you'd make sure you've pulled them out as fast as possible. It doesn't matter
if it's a Sabbath or not. You want to save their life?
So there was some way you'd break it right and here the
fact that they would not allow a healing on the Sabbath.
That this man could have been worked could have done a lot more with
his life could have lived life to the fullest then.
It showed their religious tradition.
over Road their compassion
it outweighed their compassion for people just to try to
follow the Traditions that they have.
So he confronted that then he also confronted their self-importance and
he's preparing their heart for the parable. We'll see confronted their
self-importance.
He'd watched what happened as they came into the feast and here's what he says
in response. Look at verses 7 through 11.
He gets to the Heart by saying a parable which by
the way this little confusing because the parable the wedding Feast is
what my Bible says. This is titled. It's actually not the parable worth studying
in a moment. So don't worry about that. This is a pre-parable. I
don't know. Okay, so he told a parable to those
who were invited when he noticed how they chose the places of Honor.
Saying to them when you were invited by someone to a wedding Feast Do not
sit down in a place of honor lest. Someone more distinguished than
you would be invited by him. He who invited you both will come
and say to you give your place to this person.
Then you'll begin with shame to take the lowest place.
But when you're invited go and sit in the lowest place so
that when your host comes he may say to you friend move up higher.
And you'll be honored in the presence of all who sit at the table
with you.
For everyone who exalts himself will be humble and he who
humbles himself will be exalted.
So to understand what he just said, we didn't understand what that Feast
would have been like.
The setup of it was like a head table like you
see a wedding. Sometimes now a head table where where the most important people
sit, right? Everybody's gonna look at them, but then it's staggered from
there ordered by distinguished or honored as
they would see as the host would see
fit.
And these Pharisees as they walked into Feast they
were jockeying for position because they wanted to sit at the head table or
sit up high because then they would show that they're distinguished that they're
honored.
But Jesus flipped that on its head said no. No,
actually you should humble yourself.
Instead of needing to be humbled when someone more
distinguished or more honored shows up.
Right because how awkward would it be?
For that that man sitting at the head table.
To be told no, actually we need your chair. We need
you to go sit in the corner.
The Walk of Shame awkwardness back as
everybody watches that happen.
But then think the reverse of that.
You go sit in the corner and you start there and you're just
like I'm content to be in the party. That's all I care about.
And the man who throw the party he says hey.
Come up here.
In front of everybody you get honored by walking this way.
to one of the head tables
How different that would be that's what Jesus's point was
the Pharisees thought they were special because of
who they were.
That they deserve to be at the head table. But
Jesus says no see yourself humbly. See yourself
actually how you are who you really are acknowledged that
start back here in the corner. And then
if you're going to be honored he'll do
it.
Don't be self-important.
Which led immediately to another confrontation similar vein
to that one. He confronted their social practices in
the same banquet setting.
their social practices
Not only should they not fight for position. They should also go
further and do this.
Look at verses 12 through 14.
He said also to the man who had invited him when you give a dinner
or a banquet do not invite your friends or your brothers or
your relatives or your Rich neighbors lest. They also invite you
in return and you be repaid.
But when you give a feast invite the poor the crippled the
lame the Blind and you will be blessed because they cannot repay
you.
For you will be repaid at the resurrection of the
just meaning the day Jesus returns.
Now here's what we can't read into this. Jesus was
not saying it's wrong to have friends.
He's just saying don't show Hospitality to people
so that you get paid back for it.
Instead what Jesus saying? Hey, you guys follow the law
right? You really want to follow the law. Remember Leviticus 19 says you
are to love your neighbor as yourself.
Are you really going to do that?
Because remember what love means.
Love is willing self-sacrifice for the
good of someone else even when they can't pay you back and
even when they don't deserve it.
So guys are you going to love your neighbor?
Including those who can't pay you back including those
who don't quote unquote deserve it.
Because they're remember they're practices. They're social practices
were based on what they could recoup.
I'm gonna throw this party to build up my reputation, but I know
they're going to do the same thing. So I'm gonna get to go to a party that I don't have
to pay for.
I'm gonna get that repaid.
Instead. Jesus says no focus on the Lord focus on what he
wants focus on.
Caring and loving for people who can't ever pay
you back. That's just what he's done for us. It's something
honestly, I think we need to learn today just as a sidebar.
Who are you associating with? Who are you running towards and and kind of
lean in towards to make sure that you're seen in
some way or that you're gonna get paid back someday who
you hanging with?
Social practices he confronted leading into the next confrontation from
Jesus which sets then along with verse
14 what he said about the resurrection of the just it points to the
primary focus Jesus about to say in the parable.
Verse 15 this focus on eternity. Look at what it
says. He says one of those who reclined at the
table with him heard all of this as Jesus said and he said
to Jesus blessed is everyone who will eat
bread in the kingdom of God.
So imagine this devout Jewish man.
Sitting at this Feast seeking to
follow the law.
And and he looked around at this Feast with eternity
in his mind and he saw this and and in
the room he was in he saw a foretaste of
the Kingdom.
It's like look at all these faithful Jewish people around man.
This is what it's going to be like
That the Messiah would come someday and would restore Israel.
He would give us our land back and peace perfect
people like this is the way it's gonna be.
But that assumption he's making is based on a misunderstanding
about eternity.
See, that's what Jesus is about to confront here is a misunderstanding
That they didn't actually get it.
They missed it.
And all of that that we've seen from verses 1
through 15 leads up to the parable. We're going
to study in a moment about eternity.
The story with a purpose look at verses 16 through 24 Jesus response
to this man to the whole setting he said to
him.
a man once gave a great banquet and invited many
And at the time for the banquet, he sent his servant to
say to those who had been invited come everything is now
ready.
But they all alike began to make excuses and
the first said to him. I've bought a field. I must go out and see
it. Please have me excused.
Another one said I bought five yoke of oxen. I must go examine
them. Please have me excused.
And another one said I've married a wife therefore. I cannot come.
So the servant came and reported these things to his master.
The Master of the House became angry and said to
his servant.
Go out quickly to the streets and Lanes of
the city and bring in the poor and the crippled and the Blind and the
lame.
So we assume at this point the servant goes and does that verse 22 the
servant said sir, what you commanded has been done.
And still there's room.
And the master said to the servant. Okay, go out to the
highways and hedges and compel people to come in that my house
may be filled.
For I tell you none of those men who
were invited shall taste my banquet.
Now we look at this Parable in light of
all that Jesus has confronted already in these Jewish leaders,
and we look at the principles of this parable.
And we need to understand what it's saying to us. What
is it teaching in light of everything we've seen so far.
Now here's a here's a concern a question. We have as we
study Parables every week.
How far do we go in in the
word is allegorizing these things and in taking these pieces
and say that means this and that means this and that means
it's how far do we go into that with each element? Some things
are very clear in what we know is obvious others
are less. So
and so we could go through this and we could try to make everything mean something.
But you have to remember the purpose of Parables. They're
not intended to be theological treatises.
Like statements on theology. These are
stories with the purpose of revealing the
nature of God's kingdom to us.
So our tendency is to try to dive into the weeds and try
to figure every little thing out. Don't miss the points that
Jesus is saying these words to that. It might
be pretty surface level initially.
Don't miss that though, because that's what Jesus is trying to get us to
see.
And so we're gonna look at just the principles and what it says and we'll try to identify
what those things point forward to.
The first principle we see here is that the man's party was
prepared, right?
That's the first party. He'd finished preparing. He'd sent
out to save the date cards. And now it's finished right? He's sent
out the second invitation the real one.
Now I'd already said this was referring
to Eternity.
I believe it's referring to the wedding supper of the Lamb found
in Revelation 19 where Jesus reunites with
his bride with the church.
How do I come to that? Well, because Jesus when
he's teaching about the kingdom he's talking about something that is
both already and not yet.
And what that means is that his kingdom has come in Jesus
coming to Earth and Jesus reigning in human
hearts.
But we all know that it's not fully there yet, right.
He hasn't full. He doesn't have full rain over
everything yet. So his kingdom is also not yet here.
When's that going to happen?
When he comes back at the end of days whenever Jesus returns as
the king it will all be under his authority. And
so that means
it's future. It's talking about heaven.
Also in verse 14 he talked about the resurrection of
the just that's again the last day the wedding supper
of the Lamb then he told the parable in response to the
guy's statement in verse 15. Who said this is the kingdom of God, right? He's
like no. No, actually there's something more to come.
So Jesus was talking in this Parable like
his father was the one throwing the party an
eternal feast.
and now in Jesus
coming it had been ready prepared. It's
here.
Come on in.
That's what the parable is teaching that it's prepared.
He's done it all.
But what happened when the man invited people?
His invitations were spurned, right? They were
turned away. They were refused as invitations were spurned.
Those people who were invited right they gave excuse after excuse about why
they could never come.
Can't come right now. I got I got to check a new field. I
got these 10 oxen that I just bought I got to make sure they're ready. I got
I got a new watch got married man. Come out like give me some time.
What's interesting here?
None of those excuses are sinful, right?
It's all good things. We need to work hard.
We need to take care of our families.
Those are good things.
Here's the problem in the context of the parable those
good things kept.
each person from responding to the invitation
where they got those things out of order.
They said they saw these things as more valuable than
the banquet.
and the invitation
same thing for us right good things get out
of order in our lives and they become God things to us. And
that begins to destroy us.
And so they're refusal led the man throwing the party not
to to give up his party. He didn't ask there people
refused. I'm just gonna stop I don't want to do the
party. No, he actually said I want this party to keep
going. So go gather the outcasts of
the city.
Go gather the outcasts servant.
Go gather them in now. I'm not talking he saw them as
outcasts. I'm saying the ones that Society viewed as
second class citizens. He said go get them.
Poor the crippled the lamb the blind like those who everybody
else cast aside. I want them
in.
notice the link in language
in the parable that he says go go invite all
of those people. It's the same language. Jesus used up in
verse 13 when he's talking to the Pharisees, right? He said when you
throw a party go invite the poor the crippled to lame
the blind. He said the same words in both sections.
because he's saying this temporary
party is a visual illustration of
what the Eternal party is going to be like
And I want you guys to live out what I am
doing for you.
Live it out every day.
Because remember that the Jews that he was talking to at that
moment.
They all most likely viewed the Gentiles
the non-jews as people
who are outcasts as those who are
in this category.
They would have seen no. No, there's no way they can get in.
No, we we are the ones in.
They can't make it the Nations know.
But what Jesus does here in the parable is he says actually?
My heart is for all nations to
fill my salvation house.
Like I want them all together. I got a big house. It's big big
house with lots and lots of rooms and and
the big table with lots and lots of food.
And am I the only one who remembers that right? I don't know
anybody cut that one. Okay, Audio Adrenaline. Yeah. There you go.
Okay, play football. There you go. Good one.
Yeah.
He's got a big house. He's set it up. He's prepared it. In fact,
here's what happened.
Those Jews refused to
hear and receive the invitation of
Jesus and that opened the door for the
Gentiles to hear and receive the Gospel.
That's all over scripture.
Repeated after one after another that that's
what happened whenever they said. No, we don't want you
Jesus.
He said, okay.
I'm going to the Gentiles.
The church did in Acts all over the place.
It's here in this Parable, right?
They refuse they refused they had the invitation twice refused
and he said, okay.
Go after the outcasts.
The ones that they would consider to be outcasts.
There's one more principle here at the end of this Parable. It's
that the parties refusers those who denied the
invitation were actually denied entry into the
banquet the parties refusers those who refuse the
invitation were denied.
entry
they didn't make it in verse 24 says
now again, this is not making a theological statement.
That somehow God's call is resistible.
Or that in some times. It's certain people.
It's ineffectual.
That's not saying that no. Remember Jesus was talking to
those who believed themselves to be
representatives of the kingdom of God on Earth.
To those who assumed they would
be in the Kingdom based on their family lineage.
We're sons of Abraham, of course despite their
arrogance in that despite their contempt toward
others in that and despite the fact that they refused Jesus
really was the Messiah in fact killed him
later.
Yeah, we're good.
Because Abraham is our father.
That's what Jesus told this Parable because he
wanted them to see that. It's not about Birthright. It's about
belief.
As a matter where you were born it matters, do
you believe?
And that means even those unlikely Gentiles can
get in if they repent and belief.
So again, that's the essence of this Parable it
goes back to how people responded to the man's invitation
to the party.
Did they receive it with joy with urgency?
Or do they refuse it?
That means when you take it eternally Jesus saying
this that means it's all about then what people
do with Jesus?
That's the whole.
Cut in Middle. Like that's it. It's all about
what you do with Jesus.
Now the theological work behind the scenes that's up to God how
he works all of that out, but it's still then comes down to what someone
does how they respond to Jesus.
And that's the question. He's asking them and to us really when you look at
Jesus's life death and Resurrection in your
place.
Are you in or are you out?
That's the dividing line.
And really that again is the purpose of parables in
general, right?
And this one specifically of course, but Jesus.
Used Parables to divide to separate those looking for the
kingdom looking for the Savior from those who weren't.
That's happening here.
Again, these these self-righteous Jewish leaders
were we're expecting to be at God's
table. But Jesus says actually
You might not make it in.
And they're sitting there thinking about these Gentiles who
no way they make it in. They're the unexpected ones
and Jesus saying actually
they're gonna make it in.
If they receive and believe he's getting
to their hearts. He's addressing their selfishness.
He's doing that for us every week too, doesn't he?
Like these parables are not just for those original. Here's these
are for us today. He's addressing things in us that we can drift
into the same kind of mentality that
they did. We need to be struck as well
by these things.
So three purposes here for this parable.
That we need to understand just as much today that they need to understand that
we do as well. First the principle here the
purpose is that those missing the pedigree are
actually welcome.
Those missing the pedigree are welcome and what that
word pedigree means is not dog food. It means someone's background.
someone's history
Right. It's it's what they bring to
the table. What is their pathway before that
point? And again the Pharisees assumed we're
getting in like verse 15 implied, right? The guy
was like this is what it's gonna be. Like when we're there right? They assume
they were gonna get in Jesus says, no just because you're in the
family line of Abraham doesn't mean anything.
if you don't believe
Jesus says I'm the new Vine.
I am the way to Salvation. It's not through that anymore. It's
through me.
Based on faith in him because remember when he talked about these outcasts he
was talking about Gentiles those who are unclean to
the Jews those who could never worship and he
said you guys look at them as if there's no chance they
could get in.
That's not the way you should think.
It's not about your pedigree your background history. It's about what you do with
Jesus. So hear me in this.
Don't think that that same kind of mentality can't happen today
too Church.
The way that we think about people it's not
genealogy anymore. We're not talking about that. But the way this shows
up is that some of us grew up in church, like we know all
the answers. We have kept a pretty clean external
lifestyle like like we feel kind of
worthy for this.
I I deserve to be at the head too. I
deserve to be the king look at this.
But that leads again to arrogance.
Contempt toward those whose Lifestyles don't
match up.
Who didn't grow up in the same environment who don't feel
like they deserve to get in and we kind of treat them
like they don't deserve to get in.
Somehow people are too dirty too far gone some
of you feel that right now that you were too dirty for God
and we see people as too dirty too far
gone. There's no way they're gonna get in.
Don't think this can't happen today Church.
But this Parable screams to us that
Jesus came for those people, too.
He came to the people didn't grow up in church, right? He came for the
people who the last couple days spent outside of the state capital
saying bans off our bodies. He came for the people engaging in
same-sex relationships right now. He came for the alcoholic. He
came for the drug addict. He came for the Immigrant. He came
for the poor.
And I could go on and on but many of those people the church
historically has written them off.
Has not loved them has not respected their dignity as
a person.
Is what is so compelling about jesus' love because Time
After Time and God's word. He takes those who are
far from God and he makes them his
remember the key verse in the entire Book of Luke Luke. 19:10 says
the son of man came to seek and save
the Lost.
That's what the whole book revolves around.
That means the tax collectors the sinners.
Those outside the fellowship those hated considered
by Jews as outcasts.
That's who he's talking about. He came for the Lost.
In fact the Apostle Paul wrote this same thing later. Remember the
Apostle Paul was a man who had Christians murdered.
Who spoke evil against Jesus he persecuted the
church. Here's what he says later after God saved
his life. The saying is trustworthy and deserving
a full acceptance Christ. Jesus came into the
world to save Sinners of whom I'm the foremost.
so
sinner
You are welcome here.
You are welcome in the kingdom of God.
It doesn't matter what you've done.
It doesn't matter how you grew up.
If God is opening your heart to see his
his payment for your sin to
see the invitation of Jesus. If if he's
opening your eyes to see that you have just as
much a right to come as anybody else does.
If you turn from your sin and you turn to Jesus you have
just as much a right to be in the kingdom of God as anybody
else who grew up in a perfect family.
Because Romans 9:16 says it depends not on human
will or effort but on God who has Mercy.
It's not how much you've done or how much you've not done. It's on him. It's
about your response to his grace in your
life.
But here's what happens.
He did for the Jews. It does for many people today.
What happens is what we saw with the parable of the soils a
few weeks ago right where where some people hear that
message and they have hard-hearted unbelieving soil in
their heart. They where they there's there's rocks all
in it, and it it might look like it grows for a second but it's really
shallow and it Heats of the heat of the world kind of takes over
or it grows up among thorns and all the things
the world choke out what it was doing. It's
distracted. It's worldly. That's the kind of soil. We just
saw here, right?
Jesus showed clearly that those who were
chasing the obstacles distracted.
or blocked
from the kingdom
they didn't get in.
They made excuses.
So now we
were busy.
This is more important right now.
They made excuses and the warning here is that
it's so simple for us. It's easy for
us to let competing affections in this world.
Steal away our devotion to the Lord and
it ends up destroying us.
even good things
taking God level things in our
lives destroys leads us to
be blocked from the Eternal banquet as supremely
valuable in our lives because listen, it's not only gross sin
in your life that keeps you from the kingdom.
It's also what we call more respectable sins like
greed.
materialism
Selfishness arrogant self-righteousness all these things also
keep you from the kingdom.
So we need to examine our hearts if anything else is enthroned in that
place. It must be.
removed
Slotted accordingly behind him.
And listen, you cannot delay you can't wait on this
because the final purposes Parable is the lesson that only those who
heed the urgency are included.
Did you see that?
They got the invite.
They refused it.
excluded
only those who he did the urgency with Joy
are included the first people were distracted. They cared
more about temporary things and the glory of the man throwing the feast but
the people who received the invitation responded to
it. They were the ones who got to enjoy the banquet.
And so the hard question today.
Knowing this is all pointing us to the Eternal Feast the
time Jesus returns knowing this is
about salvation first and foremost.
the question is
will you be there?
Will you be at that Eternal Feast coming someday?
Have you opened have you opened your eyes has
he opened your ears to hear his invitation to the
party?
And have you responded in Repentance and Faith
by saying you're my Lord nothing else? No, excuse you are
it?
Don't just assume.
That because you grew up in church.
Because you were baptized at eight.
Because you belong to the right group or because it looks
right in your life or you're always doing charitable things
in life. Don't just assume that you're in.
You must respond to his gracious invitation.
Because there's gonna come a day when it's too late.
Like here the end to those who refused.
Jesus will say
None of them shall taste my banquet.
And I know this is hard to hear.
But when Jesus proclaimed the kingdom of God, he was not meant to
reassure everybody who's hearing him.
He was meaning these things to shake us up.
to show us the kingdom is so different than the way of the world so
different the way we think
but he does that because listen there is nothing like the
kingdom of God.
There's nothing like this eternal feast.
And that is it's implied here. It's inherent in the
parable itself. The fact that this banquet the man is
throwing that he's prepared. He's inviting people to the banquet
itself is something to be cherished.
It's something that's better than anything else the world
can offer like he's sitting there confused. Like why would you not want to come to
the banquet?
What's so important about all that other stuff? You don't want to come here, really?
It's the point is that there's there's something different here.
And in fact what we're doing here in this room in this
moment is a foretaste of the Eternal wedding Feast
to come someday.
Right. That's why the church Gathering must be so important to us.
It's not just about checking a box and coming to church. It's because this
is a taste of what we're gonna get to do forever. Think
about what we're doing here.
We're singing praises to the lamb.
To Jesus just like they're doing in heaven right now and what
we're gonna do around that table celebrating together the
lamb who was slain in our place.
We're doing that every time we gather we're linking
arms with brothers and sisters from many nations in
Fellowship around the good news of Jesus in
our place that we're so diverse yet. We're one around
the gospel.
It's happening in heaven. It will happen forever.
We're serving One Another We're on our knees like Jesus did
on that Passover meal night where he was serving
his his disciples. He'll do it again
on that Eternal day for us. We're serving each other that kind of
way here.
As a foretaste of what's coming.
But then even think further you can see we got the table set up to the Lord's
Supper today. Think about how that
as we eat and Shrink to remind us of the broken body
and shed blood of Jesus in our place how that covering
our sin forgiving us of everything.
We have done and ever will do how that draws our
hearts to worship.
That it reminds us of the Gospel that it's a glimpse of
the joy that we will experience when
we on that day. See our groom face to
face.
And will Feast together with him forever?
This is a reminder.
A foretaste of Glory Divine something that we
can't even fathom right now. It's a taste of
it that he
the master
has made it already.
He's prepared the party. He's prepared
the feast what that means is he's done everything necessary for
your salvation.
He's done it all he's brought the invitation to
us and by his grace. He'll fill that wedding
hall with guests.
That he will invite in people who don't feel like
they deserve to be there who don't say I I am
worthy to be none of that.
By his grace were chosen to be there.
He came after us he went after us and said you
come let's go you're in my banquet.
And we by his grace will be there
if we repent and believe that is all why
we humbly agree with
what Revelation 19 shows us about that day
where he there's this Roar of many Waters the
sound of Mighty peels a thunder and everyone there is crying
out Hallelujah for the Lord Our God
the all Mighty rains that we rejoice and
exalt give him glory for the marriage of the Lamb
has come the bride has made herself ready. It was
granted her to clothe himself with fine women and bright and pure notice
granted too not we cleaned ourselves up. He
cleaned us and brought us to himself.
But here's the best part look at verse 9. The angel said
to me right this blessed are those who are
invited to the marriage supper of the Lamb?
If you have been invited.
And you get to be there.
You don't deserve it.
And deserve it.
But what?
See, it's a worship to.
To be included to have the feast forever to have
all of the blessings of God.
Do you see that church?
How blessed it is.
to be included by faith
May that change the way we respond.
in everything